[Music]
oh i'm not giving up all i need is a
little bit of luck and a little bit of
courage
to achieve all my hopes and all my
dreams ain't nobody stopping this zebra
i'm a believer i can handle
don't quit it is nothing you can't do
never stop believing in you
stick with me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey watch where you're going yeah this
park is rules you know
you could have hit someone with that
sailboat pigeons are flocking in for the
big boat race in central park
bye happy sales deals
we made it the big boat race
oh i pictured them bigger hmm
[Music]
i knew we'd find him hang tight mr bear
you're going home
we gotta hurry the sun is almost down
it's nearly bath time i'm gonna make it
all the way down there in time
we need a plan
[Music]
oh hi honey what's up she said what i
do think better on a full stomach what'd
you dump the dumplings
the dumplings i know how to get mr bear
to jakey before it's too late but i need
you all to trust me
i trust you're marty
[Music]
i don't trust you hang on mailman you
got this
[Music]
huh left
over there
it's very real mr bear but it's time for
you to go back to the arms of your rifle
person
did not see that coming